[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jason is
in San anonio Texas love your town Jason
what's up thank you sir first I will
start off by thanking you you've uh
changed my life um on our last three
real estate transactions we've
definitely been blessed and we are on
baby step 7 uh thank God way to and um
thank you sir um we are in a position
where we could potentially be looking at
a real estate investment and uh I know
you have prolific experience in
investing and I wanted to ask your
opinion on um setting up potentially a
business to uh invest in like an LLC or
under my name and then how to properly
find uh investment properties to invest
in and then uh obviously uh you know how
do we how do we manage it um you know do
we do flips do we do rentals uh what's
your opinion on stuff like that okay um
well there's a lot of different things
you can do there that's a whole real
estate course you're talking about in a
sense but the uh
um I as you probably have already
figured out I'm unusual and I pay cash
for all mine or I don't buy it so that's
thing one uh I do put all of our
properties uh in an LLC we don't buy
residential houses anymore in our
situation we've got a bunch of them but
we're not adding any when we were buying
those we uh would put uh up to $5
million worth into an LLC and then we
would form another LLC the reason for
that is if an LLC owns the rental house
the tenant gets drunk and falls off the
porch and decides it's your fault and
sues you they have to sue the owner of
the
house which is the
LLC exactly okay and if they were to win
they can take what that LLC owns but
nothing
else so your other assets like your
personal residence are then protected so
by putting your properties up to a
certain point in an LLC and then it if
once the Target on the LLC gets too big
you do another LLC so I've got a bunch
of them
um like I've got one building that's a
$15 million office building it's its own
LLC okay you see what I'm doing but if
somebody Falls over there the worst case
scenario if they get past the insurance
they get past me pipe paying lawyers to
sue them for being stupid and so on the
most they're going to get is that
building you follow me yes that
makesense so if you're going to buy a
house or two form an LLC throw them in
there now then as far as whether you're
flipping them or whether you're um uh uh
holding them then that's a completely
different strategy in in terms of what
you're looking for uh and what you want
to do and that kind of stuff flipping is
um been made famous of course by cable
television everybody thinks they're
chipping
Joanna and um I probably done
2,500 flips in my life but mostly in
another life before I did this I hardly
ever cele piece of real estate now I buy
it and hold it
forever and so uh flips are a pain in
the butt um because you're basically in
the business of renovating properties
and reselling them finding another one
renovating it and reselling it if you
want to do that as your business that's
okay but it it's time consuming you know
you're running Subs you're running paint
colors picking faucets it's like
building a dadgum house you know I mean
you're you're gonna pick roofs you're
going to do all these things and then
pull building permits you're gonna have
to do all this stuff depending on how
much work is being done to the house and
in in the proximity to a to a a city the
the municipality that you got to do that
so you got to go through all that stuff
um and after you get through all of that
you can make some money doing it if you
bought the thing right so um you just
decide if you want to do that or not on
rentals the best rates of return are
cheap
properties but they're the highest
hassle in other words the more expensive
the rent typically the classier the
tenant right more stable yeah and they
more stable but if you got lower income
property you know you're having to fight
all kinds of other misbehaviors and
other stuff in the properties but the
returns are
excellent uh
now fact 12 125,000 is about what we
have left over from the most recent sale
okay and I I just parked it in an S&P
not knowing what to do with it we can
take that and buy you know buy one or if
you want to buy one and flip it or you
and and roll it up into something but
think about what it is you want to own
for 10 years if you're buying a
rental right and from personal
experience I'll tell you you you know
you're a brand new landlord you don't
want to deal with lower income property
it's pay in the
butt I mean you it's it becomes its own
business it's your own you have to have
a a a a brain adjustment when you do it
because you have to think
different um but it you know all the all
the residential I have today is is
really high-end single families and I
don't have I got 10 or 15 of them I
don't have a bunch of them most of our
stuff is commercial but uh but uh uh so
all of that to say you just got to
decide what you want to do the but the
more
um don't underestimate the hassle factor
of what you're stepping into a flip is a
big hassle I'm telling you you make some
money but it's a job uh you know dealing
with lower income people you make a
great rate of return but it's a hassle
it becomes a job and it requires a
cultural adjustment in your brain
because they're it's a different um
psyche that you're dealing with as a
customer and so um you know by and large
not all the time but as a
generalization uh call it a stereotype
if you want to but then uh uh and then
the same thing on the other end so but
if you're going to buy something to hold
look at it and go how's this going to
age in 10 years is it already 50 years
old O then it's going to be 60 years old
when it's 10 years from now you're going
to start to you know so how old are you
Dave I know but I'm talking about houses
I mean I look at the house I grew up in
and I think that's stinking house how
old it is now oh yeah you know I mean
wow I wouldn't buy that house oh yeah
you know that's that's old yeah same the
one I grew up in yeah you know so that
that's the thing but it's a great
question um and uh and but I think the
biggest mistake this frenzy we have John
a people and Jason the people we have
out here wanting to buy real estate
right now the biggest mistake is is that
they they probably understand about 10%
of how hard it's going to be well I like
the way you're framing it because you're
saying you're asking what life do you
want and then we're going to we're going
to buy a house or flip a house based on
that because if you want to get in there
and get your hands dirty and deal with
knocking on doors and hey you can't do
this you can't light fires in the yard
what that's a life right and people you
can't run drugs out of our house that's
right and if you want to mess with subs
and have fun with doing that and
flipping it and pick faucets and that
brings you or your whoever your business
partner Joy knock your lights out but
that's a different kind of life right
yeah if you want to set it but this idea
on Tik Tok that you can just buy houses
and I've got this passive income people
who say passive income on real estate
are morons right there's nothing passive
about owning real estate it's active
right it's very active there's not I
don't own a single piece of property
that's passive right and I own about
several hundred million dollars worth oh
my God it's not passive there's nobody
there's nothing that what passive is is
mutual funds they send me a statement in
my
inbox that's all I deal with there's
that's passive but no there's not any
there's no real estate passive income
that's a that's a that's somebody trying
to sell you a get rich quick seminar on
Tick Tock or Tic Tac or whatever the
flip it is you know so that that's the
you know you just real estate is a
wonderful investment but do not go into
it folks with rosecolor glasses think
it's going to be easy it's a process
you're going to get rich quick it's not
quick it's not easy there's a hassle not
a pro it's a problem it's you know it's
like starting your own business it's the
it's the meanest boss you'll ever work
for in your life the guy will work you
into the ground you know don't start
your own business and think it's going
to fix all your problems it just makes
all your problems come home to on your
plate create your free every dollar
budget today the simplest way to budget
for your life